one click and marina settle can record
her favorite song in studio quality the
Austrian singer is testing mic me a
wireless microphone the app allows her
to process the data directly altering
the volume 2 recording individual tracks
and then combining them it's all done on
the gun before then it's so
user-friendly it's just one click for me
that's the main advantage often you've
lost your idea by the time you're ready
to record after setting everything up
and plugging everything in the
inspiration is gone the app was
developed by Philip Zod leitner and he's
hoping it becomes a market leader the
first prototype was convincing enough to
get sunlight Nuri invited to the
Pioneers festival in Vienna in May
that's a gathering for startups from all
over the world in the end 50 startups
were given a chance to present their
products and draw up investment let's
get it's not just about securing venture
capital it's also about meeting other
startups yesterday I met someone from
South Korea who works in the music
business you never know what might
happen so it's very exciting Nexus
basile as respondents
the Pioneers festival provides a glimpse
of tomorrow's world one that might be
populated by robots that can imitate
human expressions a Berlin startup has
developed software that translates
movements into music moving different
parts of the body activates different
instruments that makes each dancer a DJ
the US company Athos is embracing the
latest trend in the world of sports they
develop clothes that have sensors that
register which muscles are being used an
app then evaluates the data and provides
tips on improving the workout now you
can find a kid who's really fasted
running and then treating him how was
st. bull runs and like all the other
stars run prevent them from having
injuries and train them to the maximum
level without letting them break down
and now you can actually start evolving
human performance because you're
actually making that person better but
if entrepreneurs want to turn their
visions into reality they need to
impress people like oliver holla of
speed invest company that helps startups
through the difficult development fades
he has about 60 million euros to invest
in new projects the head of films half
of the startups that come to us aren't
ambitious enough they only think in
terms of the market in Austria Germany
or Europe they're only looking to corner
and niche that's different with most US
or global startups that of the privada
even it the founding team needs to be a
balanced team so hacker hustler hipster
they need be working on something really
interesting that they actually
authentically are interested in fixing
or sort of really working on and it has
to be a very big market statistically
speaking nine out of 10 startups fail
everyone here at the Pioneers festival
is hoping that their company will be a
game-changer in the end that's good news
for Philips on leitner he managed to
land himself a three-month stint in
Silicon Valley